(whooshing)
- Hello Believe Nation, I
made the Mentor Me series
to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more
than us and hopefully by
spending a little more time
with them some of their
mindsets, attitudes, beliefs,
way of thinking seep into us
to help us become the best
version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Bob Proctor on how
to change your paradigm.
Mentor me, Bob.
And as always, as Bob is
talking, if he says something
that really resonates with
you, please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes
around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
(soft music)
- When you're going ahead,
the only thing you can measure
is what you're giving up.
What about what's coming?
Well know what's coming? What you want.
But you've got to be
able to pay the price.
You've got to have guts,
if you don't got guts,
you don't deserve it.
- [Narrator] The opposite
of courage in our society
is not cowardice.
It is conformity.
And there you have the
trouble today is conformity.
People all do like everyone
else without knowing why,
without knowing where they're going.
- It was like a bucket of
ice water got dumped on my
head and I started really wondering,
is here something bigger?
Is there something more?
And then Bob kept saying, in
a way that only he can say,
"What do you want? What
do you really want?"
And he said, "Don't think about
what you think you can have"
he said, "Most people are
extras in their own movie.
"What do you really want?"
If you believed you could
have absolutely anything,
do what ever you want,
be whoever you wanted,
what do you want?
- Regardless of the
intellectual or physical abuse
you're subjected to, no
one can cause you to think
something you don't want to think!
You've got absolute
control over your thinking.
No one can change you if you
don't want to be changed.
(upbeat music)
Life is very short.
You're not here for a long time,
you're only here for a short time.
Every one of us are hardwired
to do something phenomenal
with our life.
We're God's highest form
of creation and we should
start thinking.
(soft piano tune)
I'm going to share some
information with you that,
it could change the direction
of your life like night
and day.
And when I say that, I want
you to really stop and take
a look at your life.
Take an honest look at your life.
I was thinking just before
I started to make this,
we have actually been conditioned
to kid with ourselves,
to lie to ourselves, to not
really take an honest look
at the results we're getting.
I want you to take a real
honest look at your results.
And when you look at them, ask yourself,
"Am I living the way I
really want to live?"
You see, most people aren't.
One of the first questions
I ask a person that comes
to work with me, I want to
know what's the most they've
ever earned in a year.
I really don't care what the answer is,
but I want to know what the answer is.
Because, you see, if a
person says the most they've
ever earned in a year is
$50,000 I know where their
mind is programmed.
If they tell me the most
they've ever earned is $250,000
I know where they're programmed.
And then I want to find
out what they want.
And I know, then, what has to shift.
Because their mind is
programmed and if they're really
going to live the way they want to live,
they've got to change the program.
And if they don't change the program,
then nothing really happens.
Do you know that the law of
attraction is always working,
it's like the law of gravity.
If I let this go, it's going to go down.
It's never going to go back
up, it's going to go down.
That is the law of gravity.
Anything heavier than
earth is attracted toward
the center of the world.
Well the law of
attraction's always working.
Now, how does it work?
Well, I use a diagram to explain the mind.
Let this circle represent your mind.
And let this little circle
here represent your body.
Now I want you to think
of this for a moment.
Your body is a molecular structure.
This is a mass of energy
at a very high speed of
vibration.
If you looked at your
body through a microscope,
you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes.
And here's something that'll
keep you thinking for the
next 20 years, when you move out of it,
the body does not stop moving.
If you go to a funeral parlor
and pick up the remains
and look at it, you will see it moving.
And if it wasn't moving how
would it ever change to dust?
You move into your body and
you will move out of it.
And it's how you use your
mind that's going to dictate
the vibration you're in.
Stay with me.
You have an imaginary
line right across here
and that separates the
conscious mind from the
subconscious mind.
Now, the subconscious
mind has been programmed.
When you were a little baby
this is the way it was.
You were just like this.
Subconscious mind wide open
and everything that was
going on around it went right in there.
And all the energy that
went in there when you were
just a little baby formed
something called a paradigm.
A paradigm is information.
It's a multitude of habits.
You are the product of your environment,
but prior to that you are a
product of a genetic strain
that goes back for generations.
Now I'm going to say that the
paradigm is X type energy.
Now you've got the ability
here on a conscious level
to think.
And you can think anything
you want to think.
And as you think you build ideas.
There's a power that's flowing
into your consciousness,
it never stops.
It flows to and through you.
You can actually photograph
this power leaving you.
It flows to and through you.
Now, as it flows in, you will
start thinking and you'll
probably think X type thoughts.
Therefore you're going to
be in an X type vibration.
And that will produce X type results.
Now it's the results you want to change.
And to change the results
you're going to have to change
what you attract.
You see, the thoughts
that you think control the
vibration that you're in.
Vibration is nothing but an
idea, it's a law of the universe
everything vibrates, nothing rests.
We live in an ocean of motion.
And it's the thoughts that
you're thinking that you
impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the
vibration the body's in and
that dictates how you act,
but it also dictates what you attract.
You attract energy that's
in harmony with you.
You attract people that
are in harmony with you.
You see, everything
operates on frequencies.
There's an infinite number of frequencies,
but you and I operate on the frequency,
just like a radio station does.
And the only music you can
attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in.
Now it's the paradigm
that's been controlling the
vibration.
You can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything,
you've got to change the paradigm.
And if you don't change the
paradigm nothing happens.
Now, talking about paradigms
is another subject,
we'll do that at another time.
But it's the thoughts that
you think that control
the vibration you're in
and that dictates what you
attract.
So if you keep attracting
what you don't want,
understand this, it's the
paradigm that's causing
the problem.
You can think a Y type thought
which is totally different
than the X type conditioning,
it isn't going to go
anywhere.
Because when you go to
get emotionally involved,
and this is the emotional mind.
When you go to get emotionally
involved with that Y type
thought, the paradigm will kick it out.
You know why?
It's so uncomfortable.
That's stepping out of the
box, that's doing things
different and we don't
like to do things different
'cause it causes a lot of discomfort.
But understand this, the
paradigm and the thinking
control the vibration
you're in and the vibration
you're in is going to
dictate what you attract.
People that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue
to attract lack of limitation.
It has nothing to do with this,
what's going on here.
This is your educated mind
and you can gather all kinds
of information.
Have you ever wondered why
some people have such an
educated mind, they have
degrees coming right off the
end of their business card,
but it doesn't show up
in the results. Why?
Paradigm.
The law of attraction.
You've got to change this.
You've got to change
the vibration you're in
and your whole world changes.
Listen, in 1961, a man gave me this book.
And he said, "Do exactly what I tell you."
He was giving me Y type
ideas, it caused an enormous
amount of discomfort, but
I did exactly what he said.
And you know something?
My income went from 4,000
to 170,000 in a year
and then I took over a million.
It took me nine and a
half years to figure out
what happened.
This is why I'm showing you.
Watch this over and over and over again.
There's a number of lessons in here.
When the paradigms
change, your life changes.
It's a beautiful concept.
It's an absolutely phenomenal concept.
Now you know why you're
getting the results
you're getting.
It has nothing to do with your intellect,
your intellect you can
figure out how to do things.
That doesn't mean you're going to do them.
You'll hear people say, "I believe that,"
but their behavior would
indicate they've never even
heard of it.
Why?
We believe something on a conscious level,
on a subconscious level
the paradigm believes
something else.
There's a word called praxis.
Praxis is the integration
of belief with behavior.
We've got to take the beliefs
that we have consciously,
that we determine by
thinking, and plant them
in the place of the old belief.
See, I used to believe
that I couldn't do anything
better than I was doing.
I felt fortunate that I
was on the fire department.
The idea of building a
company that operated all
around the world, furthest
thing from my mind.
But you know something?
As I changed my paradigm,
my whole world changed.
That's what we do.
That's what it's all about.
You've got to change your
paradigm if you want to
change your life.
You can study all you
want, if you don't gain an
understanding how to alter that program,
and that's what the
paradigm is, it's a program.
It's a multitude of concepts
that are fixed in your
subconscious mind that literally control
your behavior.
It's a beautiful concept to understand.
It's a terrible one if
you don't understand it.
Because it literally controls your life.
Why do you think most people
go right through their life
and keep getting the same
results year after year
after year?
Well, it's just the way
it is and they don't know.
We should be taught this
in school, but we're not.
How is the paradigm formed?
Through the repetition of information.
How is the paradigm changed?
Repetition of information.
Now let's suppose you're
having a difficult time
with money.
You find that you've got more
going out than coming in.
You've got to change
your concept about money.
How do you do that?
Through the repetition of an idea.
That's where affirmation comes in.
I'll give you one I've
been using for years.
I'm so happy and grateful
now that money comes to me
in increasing quantities
through multiple sources
on a continuous basis.
I am so happy and grateful
now that money comes to me
in increasing quantities
through multiple sources
on a continuous basis.
You don't just say that once or twice,
you've got to repeat that
maybe a thousand times a day
every day for maybe 90 days
and you'll start to change
your whole concept about money.
Wealthy people all have
multiple sources of income.
Now I'm going to tell
you what happened to me.
I drove around with a battery
operated record player
and a long playing record
and I played it over and over
again every day for
probably a couple of years.
It was so totally
illogical, it was behavior,
everybody thought I was losing it.
And I'm reading the same book every day,
Think and Grow Rich.
As a matter of fact, I'm
still reading the same book.
And it was the repetition
of Romant Gail's information
and the book that changed the paradigm.
I didn't know what I was
doing, I didn't understand what
I was doing, but I did it.
Do you know, I had a man
come up to me in the Waldorf
Hotel in New York, Waldorf Historia.
At the end of a three
day program and he said,
"Bob, I really want to thank
you for what you've just
"given to me."
He said, "For the first time
in my life I've understood
"how I accomplished what I did."
I said, "What did you do?"
He said, "I won the gold
medal in the decathlon in
"the Olympics in Melbourne,
Australia in 1957."
That's right.
Milt Campbell.
And he said, "I never
understood how I did it."
He said, "The next time
you run a seminar I want to
"bring my boys," and he did.
Milt and I became great friends.
In fact, Milt has a key to our house.
He can come stay there anytime he wants.
I live in Toronto, he's in New Jersey.
But he was the top athlete in the world,
best athlete in the world,
he didn't understand how he
got there.
Most people that are very
accomplished cannot tell you
why they are.
That's why they are.
They've rewritten the program,
they changed the paradigm,
they might not of
understood how they did it,
but they did it.
That's what our company is all about.
We teach people how to change paradigms.
I want to thank you for watching this.
But I'm going to ask you to
share it with other people.
Share it with them.
Say, "Come and watch this."
Start a rapport, build a
rapport with people, you know?
It's a great way to live.
And this is great
information to understand.
Thanks for listening, this is Bob Proctor.
I enjoy sharing it with you.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of the video?
What did you think about Bob's message?
What impact is it going to have?
What changes are you going
to make in your life or your
business after watching this?
What was your favorite clip?
Leave all of that somewhere
in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find
out and will join in the
discussion.
I also want to give a
quick shout-out to Ed.
Ed, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
Thank you for picking it up on Facebook,
I really appreciate it and
I hope you enjoy the read
and find your one word.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.